got himself into a little trouble over
the weekend the cheeky boy used a smoke
bug on mirage and everyone collectively
went what the f was that but what's more
surprising than this insane glitch is
that valve themselves came down from
olympus and struck it down with a hot
fix now if you've been paying attention
this is not new to municip this kit is
all about experimenting with the game
and sniffing out the bugs whether it is
creative boosts or broken mechanics if
it exists he will find that and if it
means valve has to fix everything he
breaks i say find every bug little
prince aim here
late like this
oh he's a true connoisseur this is why
they got to take inferno out of active
duty
[Music]
he baits him into it too what a little
kid genius oh my god what a little